so when the party's over I'm not gonna  interpret this song I'm just gonna sit  here and listen I'm not gonna and I  won't harmonize with you guys that's  okay it's cool it's very early people  the song has two octaves is it so in  other words this will be difficult to  perform very difficult this would be a  good test for you let's see hard enough  to do on a good day  so I say you're gonna do it alright  [Music]  don't you know no good for you  [Music]  I've learned to lose you can't afford to  soar my sure to stop you  [Music]  quiet  like that I can like  like it like  like  [Music]  already all only her to feel it  me friend but he made closer call me  back  [Music]  like in life  [Music]  well nothing is better sometimes  once we've both said our goodbyes  [Music]  [Applause]  me too  [Music]  when I'm comin home why Michael I say I  like  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  these beautiful song beautiful song and  well done